Even a show as close to perfect as Breaking
Bad is isn't completely flawless — and we've
got the collection of mistakes to prove it.
They were easy to miss, but once you notice
these errors, they're impossible to ignore.
In the first shot of the pilot episode we
see Walt's khakis float gracefully through
the air and land in the dirt, right before
an RV runs them over.
It's one of the most memorable shots of the
first season, but nothing about it makes any
sense at all.
How did the pants land in front of the same
RV that launched them into the air in the
first place?
Wouldn't they be flying backwards?
At the end of the episode, we get a different
version of the same event in which the pants
do fly backwards.
So not only does the cool shot that opened
the series make no sense, but the version
we see later doesn't sync up with it.
Luckily, we were all too wrapped up in what
was happening to care one way or the other.
In Cat's In The Bag, the second episode from
the first season, a coin flip sticks Jesse
with the horrible task of disposing of Emilio's
corpse.
Walt tells him to buy a special bin at the
hardware store that can handle human flesh-eating
acid.
Jesse can't find one big enough and decides
he'll just do the dirty deed in the bathroom
upstairs.
But while Jesse's throwing the body inside
the tub, Emilio blinks!
Maybe he'd survived Walt's poisoning, but
if that's the case he certainly didn't survive
the acid Jesse bathed him in moments later.
To be fair, neither did the bathtub - or that
entire floor of the house.
In reality, though, Jesse would've been fine.
Mythbusters tackled this sequence in a special
episode and proved that while enough hydrofluoric
acid could eat through flesh, it wouldn't
do nearly as much damage to ceramic and wood
as the show led us to believe.
Still, though: please do not try this at home
or get into the meth business and have to
worry about corpse disposal to begin with.
It's even less fun than the show makes it
look.
In the episode entitled Over, the second season's
tenth offering, Jane Margolis rebukes Jesse
in front of her father, Donald.
Jesse's hurt by the insult and corners Jane
into having the dreaded "what are we?"
talk.
During the talk Jane is snacking on a lemon
popsicle but between shots the frozen treat
goes from full, to half finished, to untouched
again, in the span of only a few seconds.
She definitely didn't have time to wolf the
first one down and open a second and we're
fairly certain she didn't regurgitate the
half she'd eaten back onto the stick.
Turns out she doesn't have that kind of luck
when it comes to throwing up.
In the third season's episode, Green Light,
Walt temporarily retires from the meth business
in order to salvage what's left of his home
life.
But Jesse recruits his idiotic friends to
continue cooking and selling Blue Sky on his
own.
He meets up with the recently fired Walt at
the high school and shows him his product
in the parking lot, expecting his former teacher
to heap praise on him for its chemical purity
and consistency.
Unfortunately, things don't go quite so smoothly.
Turns out Mr. White is far too upset with
Jesse for using his signature formula without
permission to notice that the plastic bag
full of Blue Sky meth magically switches between
a slide-to-seal pouch and a regular zip-loc.
Here's an idea, though: maybe schedule 1 narcotics
shouldn't be contained in see-through bags
to begin with?
In the season 3 finale, Full Measure, Mike
breaks into a small compound where the cartel
is holding Gus' chemical supplier,
Duane Chow, hostage.
After sending balloons into the power lines,
Mike kills the two cartel enforcers who rush
outside to investigate the sudden loss of
power.
If you watch closely you'll notice the glass
behind them shatters a split second before
he fires.
At the end of the same sequence, Mike finds
Chow alive and alone in the back, and correctly
deduces from his demeanor that one last enforcer
is hiding on the other side of the wall.
Chow raises and lowers his hands to indicate
the height at which Mike should aim his weapon
in order to shoot the enforcer.
Mike nails it.
But we have two problems here.
One, how did Mike know exactly where the man
was standing?
And two, how did he manage to send a bullet
through the wall without leaving a hole?
In the fifth season, during the episode Madrigal,
the police talk to Peter Schuler, the German
executive of Madrigal Electromotive, about
his ties to Gus Fring.
Schuler decides to off himself via Automated
External Defibrillator, and locks himself
in the company bathroom to do this.
He takes off his shirt, boots up the device
and delivers a deadly shock that sends him
to the cold floor with a sickening thud.
Problem is, even if the man had attached electrodes
properly enough for the device to detect his
heartbeat, which he didn't, the heartbeat
wasn't irregular enough to trigger the shock.
A more realistic scene would be the police
barging into the john to find a confused,
shirtless Schuler wrestling with a device
that refuses to kill him.
Walt, Mike, Jesse, Todd Alquist, and Kuby
pull off an incredible train heist in season
5's Dead Freight.
They steal precious methylamine from a train
car and replace it with an equal weight of
water so the crew won't be suspicious at their
next weigh-in.
This plan requires a lot of moving parts.
Kuby had to park a sabotaged truck on the
tracks to force the train to stop.
Mike would then tell Walt, Jesse and Todd
to begin the switch using massive tanks buried
in the sand beneath a bridge.
Here's the problem: Lydia didn't call in the
information about which train car had the
methylamine until the night before the job.
But this was after they'd already selected
the bridge and buried the tanks.
And Kuby couldn't have just parked the truck
off the side road intersecting the tracks
because that would have triggered the exact
robbery alarms the whole plan was designed
to get around.
In the fifth season episode Gliding Over All,
Walt hires the services of white supremacist
Jack Welker and his neo-nazi gang.
Their job is to eliminate the imprisoned witnesses
Hank is trying to break in order to unmask
the still-at-large Heisenberg.
In the absence of hazard pay, it's only a
matter of time until someone squeals.
Given the potential value of the targets to
the DEA, this is a tall order.
But Walt goes on to insist that the targets
be killed simultaneously so as to prevent
any of them from talking later.
Jack quips:
"Whacking bin Laden wasn't this complicated."
Problem is, this episode takes place in 2009,
roughly two years before the actual death
of the notorious Al Qaeda leader.
Did Jack know something we didn't?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Breaking
Bad are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.